so I mean like here's a question for you
guys then like what do you think of the
state of anime YouTube right now and do
you think it's in like a healthy spot
well I mean I guess compared to what's
happening on other contenders probably
thinking holy [ __ ] we dodged a bullet
for good boys and I mean like there was
a point I will admit there was a point
where I would look at the Anna Tube
community I was like there was just like
some people and just like some fan bases
as well especially just just some groups
of people where I was just like man we
don't need this kind of mentality and in
here but what can you do right
the the antigen committee or at least
the anime community online was
especially in the last five years or so
has been growing so much more yeah like
five years ago it was still very very
much a niche right yeah but nowadays
it's gotten to the point now where other
communities are starting to recognize
the size and power of the anime and
energy community so now obviously with
that is gonna come a lot of slimy
behavior from a group of people right
yeah I mean like for me it's it's been
weird seeing the an achieve community
grow as much as it has because I
remember there was a point when you
could just point to a group of people
and be like this is the Anna Tube
community anime YouTube community and
then everyone kind of like try to get
along together because the group was
small enough well you'd know everyone in
the community so you'd be viewed like
try to network and everything like that
I mean and we all tried to do that at
one point oh no no no and then it got to
a point when it the community grew too
big for it to be like under one banner
right and there were too many different
personalities for like everyone to be
able to mix and it's I feel like that
happens like I think like three four
years ago and now I feel like with with
anime YouTube it's it's a lot of
different small communities that I'd
like grouped under one general banner I
guess the gaming community right like
when I first started I'm sure all these
small creators would come together and
bang yeah but now that there are just
so many of these groups it's like small
groups within small groups
yeah I mean it's you know I bet the
fortnight streamers don't talk to the
csgo right right I mean it's different
and it's the same fanime right like you
don't know any [ __ ] Dragon Ball
youtubers but I know they are on like
that Naruto youtubers that you'll keep
to themselves yeah yeah yeah this is
weird
but it's weird because it used to be a
point when if you made anime content at
all yeah you were an anime youtuber and
now there's people like critical making
anime content like other other people
outside making anime content as well and
it's it's just become a bit more
widespread and it's it's less everyone
talks about any minute yeah yeah it's
more general now yeah you don't
necessarily have to advocate as an anime
youtuber for you to make anime content
now now everybody can make anime content
yeah yeah I always felt like you know on
the opposite interview where you were
avoiding like a core of it first yeah
yours one of the biggest yeah you've
grown with it I felt like I was always
on the outskirts of it where like I was
never friends with anyone in it really